you know what welcome to this video
I like sender Aaron that's my opponent
she's not playing yet the default again
yeah let's go for qga okay now no game
going for the London system so surprised
how popular that is nowadays I mean it
is not a bad opening don't get me wrong
but I'm still amazed that so many people
feel attracted to it um okay Knight c3
here okay he wants to go Knight b5
maybe taking on c5 no then I've got 85
yes okay okay okay yes
I just thought Luke c8 will do the trick
what is white doing yeah I mean that
really helpful to have the night on 83
okay just e6y em like a six-night back i
take on d4 I take on a3 as a
strategically terrible isn't it you can
even even even immediately Queen to b6
can be a problem what is he doing I
don't get it don't get it so I can take
on f3 now as I probably should 95 is a
problem to see have anything fancy here
Bishop f3 Knight is 7 I don't think so
that's to take take back now if I call
Queen to b6 I'm threatening a 6 most of
covering a7 but mostly I'm threatening a
6 a 693 Queen B 2 or a 3 a 693 CD 4
this is better so after Queen B 2
immediately attacking the knight yeah he
has to play something undesirable would
be one maybe
need a moment to recover from that move
long castles Jesus
well okay
now you can check on this six doesn't
even do it okay but now how do i how do
i play that it's really hot all this
Queen to a5 maybe yeah
trading trading queen says also making
the whole thing a little bit easier to
play
okay I would like to trade the bishop 56
Knight h5 is coming next
f4f six would be funny but it's not
doing that of course okay so that's a
really good point structure now I think
for me quite happy here
Knight to f4 maybe
oops maybe
can even consider to play a five in such
a position first of all I get this back
I can consider a five-year f5 Knight
back and then Knight f4 it's very stable
and his bishop is not doing anything
right age six the question here is not
the only one if he wants to go see four
I'm stopping it just to make sure that
nothing happens there's a nice piece
they only have four but it is not doing
that much it immediately
I do wanna actually make any headway he
has a hard time to somehow improve his
position
not really certain if a minority attack
is the way to do it
it's a difference now
night-night c4i he wants to go to d3 I
stupid I'm blundering ecigs god damn it
the world the funny thing is the
position is still ok for me even with
having a 6 blundered in one goal
and actually stupid game that I should
absolutely never ever lose
blundering blundering just a big porn
down
this is this is a kind of game that
always drives me nuts about you
why this just test zero chances of being
better and then you blunder blunder it
in one go
still not super easy if I'm to win why
is he giving me that pawn he gets to
gets to be six that's true
not even going to them okay
maybe I'm I'm still winning this bloody
game he plays it so badly that I can
probably still win it that's amazing
how'd you do it Jim it's the best way to
do it maybe chicken kd3 get the C pawn
going
just promoting him that was utterly
weird I mean I'm so really unhappy there
because I'm in white let's play it very
weird and I mean I had a does this kind
of position is strategically for white
quite awful because he can never do
anything and maybe surprise said the
engine gives it as equal but okay maybe
it is he for in the sense that white
doesn't have to be worse that is this
this whole opening play was so odd I
should really refute it but I didn't
manage he's six Queen a form take take
No
castle to see it's a good move them
okay take take a thought you would call
96 but somehow it didn't I felt I should
be okay even though mean okay it's got
two bishops but his pawn structure is
very bad so I felt it should be okay but
he stood ish still should do that
and now Oh Queen a seven to play b5
that's a strong wow that's really strong
yeah and you will I knew that this was a
bit lame but I had to spend so much time
so this never crossed my mind and it was
very strong before wow that's very
strong okay so Queen eight five and yeah
here I felt I should be should be better
didn't really materialize you can argue
about this f5 business by the way the
engine to the market which I was just so
terrible to blunder the pawn down I mean
I was basically playing on the increment
but still they are you you can this is
this is something you can see
I'm just kidding yourself no root defy
food that would have ended the thing
immediately I'm still yeah it was lost
but I mean you can analyze this a little
bit mortgage give me six and I mean it's
just totally over but he somehow we
somehow allowed me to take on a poor and
so here it's kind of a game a again and
now he didn't go p6 which I felt was
weird and now I'm back in this
absolutely
so yeah we k-8 John now I'm clearly
better probably winning don't think
ten inaccuracies on my end no blunder
which is funny yeah this is a funny way
of evaluating it how many huge blunder
there okay yeah thanks again for
watching